في الطريق الرئيسيه المجاور لمنزل رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني عمران خان كما ترون
الحياه عادت الى طبيعتها في هذا المكان
لكن باستثناء هذا الزحام
اقف الان امام بعض الخيام التي اقامها
حزباص عامه عمران خان لاستقبال انصاره
الذين جاءوا هنا للتعبير عن موقفهم
وتضامنهم مع رئيس الوزراء السابق كما ترون
هنا يتواجد هنا مختلف شرائح المجتمع
الباكستاني الذين جاؤوا هنا للتعبير عن
تضامنهم مع رئيس الوزراء السابق
هذه هي البوابه الرئيسيه لمنزل رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان هنا
يحتشد العشرات من انصاره على مدار الساعه
هنا تاتي عدد من المجموعات من مختلف
المناطق الباكستانيه للتعبير عن تضامنها
مرددين متافات مؤيده لعمران خان ومناوئه
للحكومه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه خيمه الاعتصام الرئيسيه لانصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان بعض المعاصمين
جاؤوا من مناطق مختلفه وبعضهم يمكث هنا
منذ عده ايام دعما لرئيس الوزراء السابق
وتحسبا لاي اجراءات قد تقوم بها الشرطه
لاعتقال زعيمهم
[موسيقى]
وكما ترون يحمل العديد من انصار رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
الهرواتي والعصي التي يقولون انها للدفاع
عن النفس ضد قمع الشرطه وبالرغم من ان
الاوضاع قد تبدو هادئه فان هذا الهدوء
ربما هو الذي يسبق العاصفه عبد الرحمن
المزيني العربيه لاهور